pour commencer pygmalion vous connaissez
le mythe de ce roi légendaire qui devait
amoureux d'une statue qu'il avait
sculpté bernard shaw s'en est inspiré
pour écrire une comédie délicieuse dont
le cinéma s'est emparé sous le titre de
my fair lady
cette comédie la voici au théâtre de
l'oeuvre dans une adaptation de claude
andré puget les décors de roger hart et
une mise en scène de pierre franck elle
est magistralement interprété par pierre
vaneck alfred adam france de la halle et
caroline cellier à laquelle paul louis
mignon posera tout à l'heure quelques
questions
le trading professeur higgins ce
spécialiste en phonétique a recueilli
une jolie bouquetière il entreprend de
faire son éducation en lui inculquant
tout d'abord les notions du beau langage
et maintenant le travail il ya peu de
rab à poser tout de suite oui vague
arrive alors j'ai des réponses on a
bientôt que vous cherchez asseyez vous
vous y êtes
dites aux à présent dit oh oh non c'est
la même chose écoutez moi bien au au
haut la cote
la côte la cote
la cour l'accord atteint la cote la côte
l'a4
je suis voyons est décédé à corte monde
ils montrent la côte budget comprend
arrière vous donc à comprendre roulement
de répéter comme un perroquet a
justement j'ai pas merkel aimerait vous
êtes une dinde
d'après moi une sorte un saut cette
saute après un saut de 10 heures nous
avons au moins vous êtes millions lui
ils sont un saut 700 têtes un seau ou
d'atteinte aux gets better way vient
d'arriver
l'avis du premier groupe écrit jean
franck duchesse de les prenez un petit
chocolat remercie tous ceux que j'ai
boirai plus tard du café au lait
sous les 1 foot président rémois qui
voir actes et pas vous
d'abord je vous demande de l'articuler
du café au lait mais en fait la
différence articles et du café au lait
la leur alors la hollande au rav dans le
van hove envol en bradant caché avec le
paddock est fâché avec un choix soit
elle est très loin
ne nous emballons pas nous en parlons
dans quinze jours continueront y en a
encore pour longtemps
et en plus de ça il en faut
et d'après moi la pluie en l'espagne va
se maintenir dans la plaine donnant en
colère que question de coeur quoique à
dix et après que chez moi la peur je
travaille sortez moi y compris
pickering moi c'est moi la voix de bic
est sur le bureau pour janvier regardez
vous voyez ces trois billes envers ses
deux passes vous allez mettre dans votre
bouche que vous venez jeter encore vous
il faut que malgré ses filles vous
arriviez à prononcer très distinctement
s'il n'y arrivais pas je vous prends par
les cheveux et je voudrais le double de
la pièce pendant une demi heure je ne
pourrais pas me connaissez pas
directoire et et moi je crève les yeux
moment donné il est gentil ladies a
essayé on faisait bien beau que je fais
sinon pita pas moi le quart sud est de
la côte ont influencé tant par des
résidus pluvieux stagnant sur le relief
que par une dépression à l'ouest de la
chine
[Musique]
l'important je l'aimerais afin
d'éprouver les résultats de sa méthode
je le professeur confronte son élève
avec les gens de la haute société au
cours d'un thé chez madame higgins sa
vénérable mère question pensez vous que
nous allons avoir la pluie en espagne va
se maintenir dans la plaie
et chez nous le quart sud est de la côte
sera influencé tant par les résidus
pluvieux stagnant sur le relief que par
une dépression à l'ouest de nos îles à
ce qu'on dit
diderot qui est il de drôle là dedans
bonjour monsieur résister
j'espère que le temps ne va pas se
mettre au froid comme en hollande dans
le fun nord
le fadoq est fâché avec un rap soir
à
parce qu'ils les ont moi tout ce que je
demande c'est ne pas attraper le russe
est une véritable maladie m'attendais
morte d'un rhume
très moi c'est ce qu'on a prétendu mais
à mon avis on a dû la butée
butin car pourquoi seigneur dieu serait
telle mortes dans la rue et qui s'était
sorti drôlement biya l'année d'avant une
dictée riz de derrière les fagots
les vues elles étaient déjà bleu on
croyait qu'elle était clamser alors mon
père n'a pas arrêté de lui verser jean
dans le gilet jusqu'à ce qu'elle est
revenue à elle si brusquement qu'elle a
cassé la cuillère d'un coup de dent avec
le bol partie de marche t il alors dit
franchement est ce qu'une femme de cette
force là tu en direct la beauté aussi
bêtement pour un petit coup d'oeil à
tous
réponse ans non ce qu'il faut plutôt se
demander c'est tout a bien pu passer son
chapeau de paille tout neuf qui devait
me revenir et bien moi je réponds que
quelqu'un le lui à fouchy que ce
quelqu'un qui le lui a reproché c'est
celui qui l'a buté
voilà c'est q que signifie but est à
terme du dernier argot à la mode du thé
signifie tuer service vous croyez tout
de même pas qu'on a buté votre je crois
ce qu'il vivait avec il aurait refroidi
pour une épingle à chapeau alors vous
rapportez vous pensez team cyrus était
monsieur n'est ce pas fier en exqi une
trouvaille c'est pas que votre père
avait déjà comme une bien grande
imprudence en lui faisant ingurgiter
autant de jean baudet tout c'était une
femme qui vous traiterez 110 femmes
nourrissent en sus de l'état ne l'a vue
du raid d'habitude de samba lancer de
telles quantités derrière la cravate qui
savait par expérience de bien que ça
fait en salle basse
vous ne voulez pas dire qu'ils paient
régulièrement aussi c'est même la seule
chose qu'il faut c'est aussi
régulièrement le genre chronique à ce
qu'on dit comme ça a dû être pénible
pour vous là jamais rendu malade
ils sont envoyés en l'air deux ou trois
fois par semaine et quand il avait bien
biberonné je venais beaucoup plus gentil
si des fois ils restent sans bosser
comme cela le fichier mauvais poil
ma belle mère lui refiler des sous pour
qu'il a la peau qui lui revient plus
sentimental il ya des femmes comme ça
voyez vous il faut qu'elles sous leurs
maris pour vivre un peu mieux
eh ben c'est forcé n'est ce pas quand un
homme un réelle conscience le cafard le
prends toujours dès qu'il est en panne
sèche tandis que lorsqu'il a fait le
plein il oublie tout la vie est belle il
embrasse vous rigolez comme ça non mais
c'est à cause de ce nouvel arbre à la
barre
vous oubliez aussi violent qu'on fait
tous mourir de rire si j'en est bien il
est inutile de mettre en caisse est-ce
que j'aurais dit quelque chose que je
n'aurais pas dû dire
mais absolument pas mademoiselle bah
tant mieux
c'est ce qui s'appelle avoir dit font
remarquer parce que parce que je venais
chez vous je me suis dit là bas fils
s'agit de père regarde étonné que c'est
la première fois
[Musique]
je vais vous demander la permission de
me retirer ma dang et j'ai encore deux
ou trois visites à faire et je ne
voudrais d'ailleurs pas abuser de votre
charmante hospitalier
vous avez très jeune carrière comment
êtes-vous venu au théâtre je crois avoir
lu que vous écriviez des pièces comme
vous êtes sceptiques n'ont jamais écrit
deux pièces
mais le parcours bruit c'est un faux
bruits oui quand j'étais petit en fait
je j'adorais le théâtre j'ai aimé ça
mais je savais absolument pas j'étais
capable d'en faire j'avais une amie qui
était comédien j'avais très souvent au
théâtre et j'ai continué mes études et
j'ai décidé un jour d'aller au cours
simon le jeudi après midi mais sans
aider encore arrêté de faire du terrain
dans son idée retis de faire du théâtre
du tout parce que je savais pas du tout
si j'étais capable surtout et puis il a
déjà d'autres ambitions à ce moment là
pour l'instant je faisais mes études et
je faisais mes obligations jeu des
études chez ea sports mais et surtout je
vous dis j'ai adoré le théâtre de mes
occupations c'était aller au théâtre
chaque fois j'en avais chaque fois j'en
avais envie surtout chaque fois que
j'avais l'occasion d'y aller
et donc j'ai pris des leçons chez rené
simon des cours le jeudi après-midi
alors c'était surtout des cours de
diction des cours de maintien
ça nous apprenait comme je suis très
timide
j'étais très timide c'est encore plus à
ce moment là ça m'a appris à libérer un
peu et puis petit à petit ça m'a
passionné plus en plus et j'ai abandonné
mes études passer le bac et j'ai
abandonné mes études et je la plains tu
en es tu là
je suis resté un an et j'ai passé le
concours cette année là j'ai eu un
premier prix prix marcel achard et ça
m'a fait démarrer au théâtre chez renée
dupuis c'est un des puits qui m'a fait
démarrer au théâtre et à la télévision
roger leenhardt
votre principale école a donc été le
théâtre presque aussitôt après ses
premiers coups est ce que vous regrettez
ne pas voir par exemple aux tentes et le
conservatoire je devais faire le
conservatoire
simon avait présenté au concours mais
comme j'étais une jeune élève je crois
pas qu'il s'imaginait que je déballerai
tout de suite et il m'avait dit après
concours l'année prochaine tu
présenteras conservatoire et comme j'ai
joué tout de suite
aussi bien au théâtre qu'à la télévision
j'ai pas pu rentrer au conservatoire ça
m'a bien sûr ça m'a manqué pour la
formation classique qui est très
importante mais je n'avais fait quand
même énormément encore ciment et puis je
crois qu'on apprend merveilleusement son
métier en jouant faisant et je suis pas
tellement pour rester des années des
années dans un court mais jouer au
théâtre pour vous êtes vraiment un
besoin
ah oui quand je parle moi je suis malade
je suis pas malade suggère mai
mais je suis très malheureuse parce que
c'est du tout enfin d'abord de jouer
puis l'ambiance du théâtre même
l'ambiance des répétitions est
merveilleuse vous avez joué longtemps la
même pièce ou renouveler ce plaisir
longtemps et pas trop une saison je
crois que c'est bien est-ce que ce ce
succès qui qui vous saisit depuis deux
saisons en particulier pose des
problèmes parce que vous pouvez ménages
et la vie personnelle
le travail de la comédienne qui
finalement de la télé
théâtre travail doit être assez mal
accaparant oui oh c'est à dire que je
travaille tout le temps je crois est
comme ça me
ça m'amuse c'est me ça me passionne ça
m'amuse beaucoup alors je m'amuse en
travailleur c'est par fiche parce qu'il
ya des rôles qui vous tente
particulièrement c'est la question
traditionnelle
j'aimerais faire tout les tragédiennes
etc en tragédienne bien sûr mais j'ai
programme rester dans le comité allemand
quel rôle de tragédie j'aimerais jouer
génie j'aimerais jouer a fait tous les
routes que j'ai d'ailleurs travaillé
dans les manches et simon mais je crois
encore que j'aime
[Musique]